here are a few moments completely out of
context from tatsuki fujimoto's chainsaw
man a headless turkey becomes the school
pet for a group of high school students
a girl is forced to play DDR while
having a full-scale panic attack there's
a tournament for kicking a man in the
balls a guy made of chainsaws rides a
shark like a horse using chainsaw chains
as Reigns in order to fight a giant baby
from a glance chainsaw man looks like a
story derived by someone utterly [ __ ]
deranged
it's hyperviolent page is soaked with
copious amounts of blood and gore
accompanied by the kind of humor you'd
expect to hear in a freshman High School
class Playing Cards Against Humanity but
in between the moments of insanity
the violence the crudeness is the kind
of heart and sincerity that has brought
me back to its Pages again and again a
Shonen story with a pulpiness and
texture that makes the series stand
apart from its contemporaries and Shonen
jump and now with the anime by Studio
map of Jujutsu kaisen Fame right around
the corner and a lot of new fans finding
out about the series for the first time
I wanted to sit down and really talk
about it I'm red Muffler Man
and today I'd like to introduce you to
the sincere insanity
chainsaw man and why you need to watch
it
[Music]
chainsaw man began its run in weekly
Shonen Jump in 2018 and was the
brainchild of one tatsuki fujimota
Fujimoto at the time had been known for
his work on the manga fire punch in
2016. a series known for
being [ __ ] batshit
to give an example Fire Punch opens in a
world which has been thrown into a
second Ice Age and the main character
has the ability of endless regeneration
which he uses to cut off body parts in
order to provide food for the people of
his village as well as his sister who is
uh kinda into him
uh his village is slaughtered by the
government for being cannibals and our
protagonist is then set on fire by a guy
whose ability is to summon infinitely
burning flames which causes our main
character to burn endlessly
however his powers of regeneration keep
him alive even through the pain from
there he blazes a path through the snowy
Wasteland on a literally and
figuratively burning quest for vengeance
I've known writers who have used subtext
and they are all cowards
fujimoto's work on fire punches
fantastic and honestly I might make a
video about it one day but needless to
say it perfectly exemplified fujimoto's
style of Storytelling stories of uncanny
broken people going through absolutely
insane situations people that despite
everything they have gone through or the
things they've done are still very human
and after cutting his teeth in the pages
of Jump Plus with fire punch Fujimoto
began his serialization of Chainsaw man
in the pages of weakly Shonen Jump
chainsaw man is the story of denji a
broke kid who through a series of
incredibly Unfortunate Events has been
thrown into a debt from the Yakuza
singing to the tune of roughly 38
million yen which totals to about 250
Grand in US dollars
to work off this insane debt denji Works
a variety of odd jobs
he cuts down trees sells his kidneys his
left eye his uh
testicles oh God we're gonna get
demonetized but by denji's side he has a
single friend pachta a dog-like creature
with a chainsaw sticking out of his face
and together the two of them attempt to
pay back that debt hunting Devils now
devils are essentially a race of
supernatural beings that feed upon the
fears of humanity so if you have
something that you're afraid of there's
probably a devil for it you have Devils
ranging from the Cockroach devil the
fish devil the Tomato devil the sea
cucumber devil the chicken devil
okay yeah this is the part of the video
where I tell you
yes
I know I called him a turkey at the
start of the video
that was to purposely bait you into
leaving comments telling me that I was
wrong in order to boost the engagement
on this video
if you fell for it then just know
I am always
one
Step Ahead
but devils in the world of Chainsaw man
can range from just minor inconveniences
in a household to brickingly apocalyptic
hell spawn and so it's up to devil
Hunters to act as a kind of
extermination Squad to keep them in
check so denji risks life and limb every
day to get the bounties for killing
these Devils of which nearly everything
he makes is taken from him by the Yakuza
for his debts leaving denji with barely
the money to even buy a loaf of bread
dingy situation has gotten so bad that
ideas like being able to eat toast with
Jam in the morning or to be able to talk
to a girl all of these feel like
astronomical Feats that he would never
be able to achieve in his lifetime
denji lives a life of Despair but since
despair is all he's ever known it's
something he's become accustomed to
and so denji dreams
because the world has taken everything
from him
but no one
can take away his dreams
but Dengue and pochita just can't catch
a break and after being lured into a
trap set by the Yakuza both denji and
pochita were murdered
left for dead inside of a dumpster
but in their final moments
the two combined with one another in
order to stay alive with pochita the
chainsaw devil acting as denji's heart
newly awakened denji becomes chainsaw
man a being neither human nor devil
but something
in between
from here denji is found by the
mysterious makima a woman working with
the Japanese government for a division
of devil Hunters
she gives denji an ultimatum to either
be hunted down and killed as a devil or
to be her lap dog to hunt Devils as a
human
Genji accepts and begins his new life in
Tokyo as a professional devil Hunter
denji's Journey from the pit of despair
is
pretty touching but what really sets him
apart in my eyes from your dekus your
tanjiros your Luffy's is that denji
really acts his age
he acts like a head teenager he's crude
he's awkward and blunt with people Genji
will say some of the most
cringe-inducing [ __ ] like challenging a
devil to a dream battle or agreeing to
kill a devil if it means he gets to make
out with one of his co-workers he's not
trying to be some hero of Justice or
trying to avenge the death of his family
or anything Noble like that
stupid kid living up the life that was
taken from him he lives by his own set
of morals so whenever he does something
that anyone else in the story thinks is
insane to him it makes perfect sense
it's always a blast to see what sort of
insane idea denji comes up with in the
middle of a fight and then hearing the
bat insane justification for it and then
being like
that actually makes sense what the [ __ ]
but denji also has a real
Human Side to him there are moments of
introspection in denji's Journey that
have kept me up at night
to give some context I'd like to talk
about a small scene from the manga there
are some minor spoilers so if you would
like to avoid them please skip ahead to
the time stamp I've listed below
in this scene denji has just defeated
the leech devil and rescued Power one of
his devil hunting co-workers in order to
thank him for this power lets him uh
cup of feel
no no no no don't leave I I promise this
is going somewhere
a cop a fee
this is something Dengue has dreamed of
for a long time and
he did it
he lived his dream
but
he's not happy
there's no joy
denji just feels
empty
the thing he had dreamed of for so long
was nothing like what he thought it
would be
that the journey to get to that point in
his life
felt kind of meaningless
and now that he'd achieved that dream he
felt lost
with no goal in sight
I think about this scene
a lot
I've had a lot of Dreams in my life that
I've worked insanely hard to achieve
grinding myself to the point of absolute
burnout Knights of crying to myself
silently wondering if the pain of it all
is even worth it or if I'm even good
enough and then even when you make it
you find out there is
no such thing as making it that you
never stop chasing that the goals you
hold Aloft so high at the end of the day
will feel empty when you finally grasp
them in your hands
when I read this I had to stop for a
good 30 minutes as I kinda just
sat there
one of the biggest struggles I had ever
felt in my life as a young adult
had been laid perfectly bare to me in
less than five pages
[Music]
then I remember this scene is about
boobs
these moments of sincere introspection
are littered all throughout the story of
Chainsaw man you can feel the years of
lived experiences that Fujimoto puts
into the pages of this story and it
makes denji feel so very
real
and it's not just dingy the entire cast
of Chainsaw man has a real texture to
them all of them with their own sets of
morals and beliefs their own motivations
for doing the things that they do
for example Aki who serves as the main
foil to denji is single-mindedly focused
on a thirst for vengeance but over time
begins to develop a soft spot for the
comrades he fights with
as such
struggles with the fact that he's using
the people around him for his own goals
power who on the surface appears to just
be a mad serial killer but only acts so
because it's the only life she's ever
known cobeni who is just
normal
but has to deal with the fact that the
world she lives in is insanely [ __ ] up
I love her she's my favorite yes I'm
very basic and makima who takes the
supernatural in stride acting as an
observer to the world around her even
the smallest of Side characters have
some of the most insane backstories and
motivations imaginable such as cosmos
whose literal only character traits are
that she can only say the word Halloween
and she is a lesbian and then it turns
out she has the most metal backstory
ever holy
so [ __ ] cool but that texture that
sincerity it makes getting close to
these characters feel more like getting
close to real living people it makes it
feel so when something crazy happens
those moments feel real no matter how
insane things get you're invested and it
also makes the story
that much more heartbreaking when these
characters whom we've grown so close
with are
suddenly ripped away I'm not going to
beat around the bush
chainsaw man for every moment of
insanity or close introspection or
off-color humor or insane violent
spectacle we'll have another moment of
sheer heartbreak and Terror
at any moment a character can be killed
on sanctimoniously
no Flags
no warning
just death many times the death won't
even register with you at first
just like in real life it's
sudden
then the realization hits
slowly not just for our cast but
for the audience
the theme of death is ever present in
the pages of Chainsaw man
and while that can sometimes be a downer
it's also one of the places where
fujimoto's art style
truly shines
Fujimoto renders his characters to be
closer to what one would expect from
real human anatomy rather than having
them look more in line with traditional
anime while at times this can lead to
his characters looking somewhat uncanny
it also means that Fujimoto can play
with the expressiveness of his
characters
this can lead to moments of pure
Euphoria painted all over a character's
face or much more likely
the feeling of Terror and Dread of
having to face how cruel the world can
be
this expressive visual design also
carries over to the look and feel of the
Devils a majority of the devils are
these surreal pictures of body horror
looking just human enough in their
appearance to elicit a feeling of
discomfort that something is obviously
wrong that this thing
was once a person
from the strange imagery of a
decapitated head walking around with a
foot and hand sticking out of its neck
to a woman wearing a dead smile made of
countless sets of arms or even dengie's
bloody industrial transformation into
chainsaw man gives the show an unnerving
edge that only adds to its brand of
Horror
and one thing I can say for sure about
the anime is that the trailers seem to
be taking this visual style and Running
With It characters are just as
expressive as they are in the manga if
not more so and the dark color palette
sells the mood of the show incredibly
well the few action shots we've seen
from the trailers have been ridiculously
over animated Feats of pure sakuga the
hell every episode of the first 13
episode core will have its own ending
credits animation not to mention the
staff behind this anime are All-Stars
Studio mapa of Jujutsu kaisen Fame also
who famously overworked their animators
because the Japanese animation industry
is fundamentally broken music composed
by kensuke ushio who did the scores for
Devilman crybaby a silent voice and ping
pong the animation as well as a slew of
other incredibly talented artists who
have worked on everything from SSS
gridman Mobile Suit Gundam ironplated
orphans mob psycho 100 Space Dandy flip
flappers bro you need to watch flip
Flappers oh my God everything about the
adaptation for chainsaw man is leading
me to believe that it is going to be the
next big thing in anime and it's why I
implore you if you're on the fence
please give the show shot or Hell read
the Manga which recently came off of
Hiatus and still continues to make me
laugh but has also unnerved me to my
absolute core there's not been a day
that has gone by since January of 2021
that I've not thought about this story
at least once you need
to watch chainsaw man
thank you so much for watching as per
usual if you like everything we do on
the channel feel free to drop a like a
comment and hit that subscribe button
and if you like me and what I do you can
follow me on Twitch Twitter and YouTube
and red Muffler Man I'm incredibly happy
I got to talk about the story with you
today and I really honestly hope you
give it a shot and
maybe love it as much as I do and uh
yeah have a good one everybody
take it easy